[Music]
more scenes of Harvey and the damage in
Houston the disaster is pushing the
limits of Houston's emergency call
services 911 operators processed 75,000
calls between Friday night and Monday
morning
normally the city gets eight to nine
thousand nine one one calls a day many
people who need help have complained
about their calls going unanswered
Jericka Duncan went inside Houston's
emergency center to see what officials
are doing she's in Westfield Texas
Eureka good morning good morning these
floodwaters are keeping that emergency
9-1-1 center incredibly busy officials
there say when people call 911 and they
don't wait to listen and hear for
someone it actually creates a backlog
they say and that could mean even longer
amounts of time for the police and
rescue crews to get to people in need
when Harvey moved in and started
dropping historic amounts of rain in and
around Houston many people who wrote out
the storm dialed 9-1-1 as floodwaters
rose on a regular basis we get
approximate 8,000 and 9,000 calls but
this morning alone you had 75,000 that
is correct we have a great staff Joe
Lauda's administration manager at the
houston emergency center for people who
are stranded let's say on their roofs
are you getting police there immediately
or how does that work right now we
prepare that information for dispatch
purposes and of course we can't speak
for the police and fire response because
they are tied up with so many
emergencies as well laud says the 9-1-1
problem is complicated when people hang
up and try calling back should they be
doing that no no no we are advising
people to go ahead and stay on the line
the worst thing they can do is hang up
because what ends up happening is almost
there back at the end of line more than
200 people have been working 12-hour
shifts since Saturday normally just 25
people are answering these phones
for Catherine Tyler the work has become
personal take a deep breath man
what's keeping you going and motivated
you lost your car your home I love you
doing I've been doing this job for about
four and a half years
they need help my co-workers have been
working long hours I needed to get here
home aside from dealing with stress of
trying to get people who need to be
rescued these call takers are actually
giving an increasing getting an
increasing number of calls about women
in labor so they are literally talking
people through home delivery scale Thank
You Jericka everybody working overtime
doing what they need to do thank you
very much